[Musique]
ce sont tous les médecins l'initiatives
avaient été lancées par un nouveau
groupement qui est pas encore à syndicat
qui s'appelle venir médecine et à partir
de là l'ensemble des syndicats
c'est-à-dire la totalité des syndicats
médicaux et Dieu sait si il y en a pas
de temps il a bien 6 ou 7 tous se sont
jointes à cette initiative du premier et
du 2
[Musique]
essentiellement la décharge
administrative la décharge
administrative c'est à dire qu'on nous
donne les moyens d'embaucher du
personnel qui soit rémunéré bien sûr
selon son travail et qui nous décharge
du tiers au moins de notre activité ce
qui nous permettrait pendant ce temps de
voir beaucoup plus de personnes et
améliorerait le service de son ceci
passe effectivement à part augmentation
de la rémunération ou bien par la prise
en charge de assistant médicaux
directement par l'assurance maladie ou
sous une autre forme
toute personne qui dans la journée en
temps normal a besoin d'un médecin même
pour une pathologie qui n'est pas
urgente urgente mais qui veut voir un
médecin dans la journée appelle le 15 et
le 15 dispose de créneaux disponible
dans chacun des territoires pour y
adresser des messages en principe la
régulation du 15 devrait être à petit
chargé et renforcer au niveau de
personnes qui répondent
[Musique]